[Musique]
j'aimerais vous demander à quoi on
reconnaît une fille est belle michel
salles voûtées
mais qu'est ce qui fait la beauté de la
kia la jeunesse parce qu'une vieille
dame
on voit quand on ne peut pas être joli
quand on est vieux
[Musique]
caroline tu es contente de ce qu'il
vient de dire ça ne fait pas plaisir que
patrick ne trouve jolie ça te gêne un
peu alors qu'est ce que tu en penses
les deux d'abord hier cinq minutes pour
les cours n'étaient dollars patrick
kiliba j'aime pas caroline joue pas mais
en tout changer tout d'elle mais on peut
changer d'avis pas sur ce sujet toi par
exemple qu'est ce que tu penses de
caroline est ce que c'est une jolie
fille mais elle est à côté de toi
regarde là mais non je ne peux pas
pourquoi pas toujours qu'elles soient
grandes ou saucisson sourire qu'elle
soit gai que l'un sourire que les
joyeuses qu'elle sait parler pas comme
que quelqu'un par exemple qui est avec
un garçon ça parce que c'est un garçon
ça génère l'on savait à quoi tout timide
non moi je trouve
comment est-ce qu'on voit que quelqu'un
est beau ou n'est pas beau moi je vois
la carte est ce que tu pense qu'il vaut
mieux être beau intelligent dans la vie
qu'elle est née de l'idée
oui mais si on devait choisir ah si on
devait choisir la traiter les gens comme
ça compte beaucoup l'otan ceci on est en
forêts exemple je crois que ça sert à
rien et si vous pouviez changer quelque
chose à votre corps ou à votre visage
qu'est-ce que vous changeriez
jean-françois lenny et fabien qu'est-ce
que tu décroches il élevé qu'on
m'appelle rocard qui a déjà 10 à jean
françois mézy pas ici mais les comptes
chez moi ça c'est pas très très bien ça
[Rires]
pour quoi
quelle occasion aimerais tu vas voir
mais j'oubliais on n'est jamais content
de ce qu'on a parce que il ya peut-être
qu'ils ont des yeux bleus et qui
aimeraient avoir des yeux bruns tout ça
c'est pour le corps humain maintenant à
quoi voit donc une musique est belle ça
dépend des goûts tout ça c'était pour
les goûts et les couleurs automnales
chacun un goût différent et couleurs
différentes et musique c'est normalement
la musique classique on a emporté la
dedans tu écoute de la musique à fond
mais emporté et que tu te citer 1 un
morceau qui tend portent
particulièrement ou un compositeur qui
posa des choses comme ça et maintenant
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'une peinture est
belle quand elle est blanche bien
blanche qui a pas dû de la crasse noir
dessus
[Musique]